did you know Kang the Conqueror AKA
Jonathan Majors was recently booked on
charges of assault harassment and
strangulation Jonathan Majors was
arrested Saturday March 25th for a
Litany of pretty terrible crimes it's a
huge blow to what seemed like the
quickest and hottest career path for an
actor in recent years I mean it seems
like almost overnight Majors went from a
talented but unknown actor to like the
biggest thing in Hollywood Creed 3 Loki
quantumania Army commercials the man has
shot up to the A-list in a seriously
fast way and with good reason he's hella
captivating on screen but this recent
arrest might just be putting all of that
to a halt now Majors his lawyer has
publicly said that there's video
evidence that exonerates him so maybe
this won't proceed any further than a
little bad press and Majors will
continue his path upwards but if he's
convicted of these crimes things could
get drastically different for this
up-and-coming star